Prince William always chooses his words
carefully and has he met young homeless
LGBT people rejected by their families
he used the public moment to speak
personally when asked what he would do
if one of his children was lesbian gay
bisexual or trans this is something I'm
nervous about not because I'm worried
about the pressures as you they're gonna
face at home much harder their life
could be so for a parent pointed out
that I worry about is is is that I wish
we lived in a world that it was a
like-new surf house really normal
you know cool but particular for my
family in the position that we are in
that's the bit I'm nervous about the
charity hosting him praised the Prince
saying his comments would make a huge
difference I think that having a high
profile person such as Prince William
say that can hammer home to parents that
you know whatever their child come up
comes out with that they're able to
provide that background so that that you
know somebody in the royal family can be
accepting the child then so can they
the Duke of Cambridge said he and his
wife had talked recently about the issue
many feel this is a significant moment a
future sovereign admitting his own
children might struggle if they were
LGBT because of the royal roles they
hold and in the middle of Pride Month as
preparations gear up for pride in London
the princes message of support was
welcomed I think it's definitely big a
big social moment in terms of the fact
that quite a lot of people look up to
the royal family as role models and see
them as a bit of a barometer but I think
the real litmus test would be if we did
have an LGBT monic it's absolutely
amazing at Prince William's welcoming
and any LGBT child specifically feels
his own but I think the bit that people
should take away is but there's still a
long way to go when it comes to LGBT
rights it's not the first time Prince
William has supported our gbt issues he
appeared on the cover of Attitude
magazine three years ago and speaking
out again he knows his words will be
heard although
the world Nora boondocks Sky News